[Applause]
yeah thank you and I mentioned earlier
to a friend but you know that you're
among a bunch of passionate people when
they show up to talk about prop elastic
programming at 11 o'clock on a Sunday so
very grateful that everyone for being
here start because probably is called
probabilistic programming in the real
world the intention is to expose
prophecy programming to someone who's
maybe not familiar with it or slightly
familiar with it hasn't dealt with it in
industry and wants to know what kind of
problems can I can I apply this to
what's the way this works under the hood
a quick couple of public service
announcements so first off thanks to a
Capital One for hosting us this has been
an excellent conference also Travis Olaf
on yesterday mentioned you should
support non focus and you should so I
wanted to to put that out there if you
are not a sustaining member it's not
very expensive in a lot of us including
myself
so our careers to numb focus so I would
encourage you to please if you weren't
or even if you are to throw some money
toward them focus and finally I am on
the organizing committee for a machine
learning conference there's taking place
in April called the TomTom applied
machine learning conference or a MLC so
two things you should definitely go to
that conference if you are going to be
in the area it's going to be in a movie
theater so we have theaters that we rent
out downtown Charlottesville and we
bring in about 500 people to come watch
machine learning talks in movie theaters
and you should also give a talk
so our RFP is open now and that's a link
that you can click on but if you just
search TomTom man you'll see also put
these slides make them available and
that would be a clickable link I think
that's open till the end of December so
if you have something kicking around
please
please go ahead and it's a bit a little
bit about me this is we already went
over but I'm a lead that is scientists
at SMP global market intelligence in
Charlottesville Virginia I work on a web
platform for financial professionals and
I focus primarily on problems in search
so natural language processing as it
applies to getting people to the content
they're looking for within a very wide
and subject specific domain I am
passionate about solving problems and
hanging out with my wife her name is
Kylie and our dog whose name is boom
so I wanna get started with sort of a
toy example that that is not toy to me
because I think about this a lot how
funny is my joke so the joke is why are
the chickens studying machine learning
across the road the punchline is the
answer is trivial and is left as an
exercise to the reader so if you were
gonna you're gonna rate this joke on a
scale of one to ten who would give this
a seven or above who would give this
between four and seven and who would
give this between a one and A four so
that's probably about what I expected
but but let's let's play this out so if
we assume that joke funniness ranges
from one to ten on a continuous scale so
we're not discrete we can we can have
partial rankings joke funky joke
funniness is truncated normal so we'll
have a normal distribution around this
scale but obviously we can't go above
ten or below zero and if we don't have
any expectation for given jokes
funniness a priori so I can't come in
and say well you know my jokes are
typically around at nine so that's what
that's what we expect this one to be in
that case we can actually make a model
and say well given observations that I
make around people writing my joke
how funny can I expect my job to truly
be and so this is this some ratings that
I got hanging out around Charlottesville
I asked for people I got three fours and
a three on that joke and this is a pie
mc3 model that I'll walk through for
everyone as a context manager by say
with this model and I get give it a name
just a reference Majok model I need to
define priors on my truncated normal
distribution which is going to describe
this joke so I'll create a uniform
distribution over the mean of the joke
and then I'll just go from 1 to 10 so I
don't that the the completely non
informative prior doesn't bias me toward
anything high low or medium and then I
have a standard deviation of my
funniness and that's gonna be a half
coachy distribution mostly because that
tends to make sense in a standard
practice but half coachy extends really
far to the right and cuts off at zero so
half coat you can't go negative and then
when I define my funniness
I'll say my observed funniness is a
truncated normal distribution it's got
me
that's defined by this this prior a
standard deviation defined by this prior
it can range from one to ten and I
observed these four elements and the
beauty of probabilistic programming is
that's essentially all I have to do and
it's all in Python and I can click
what's called the inference button
people usually put a trademark on this
when they presented it at PI datatype
talk so it's the the inference button TM
and I can essentially say what will get
to what all of these all these all this
code means but it essentially doesn't
vary for any probabilistic model but I
can say given the model that I've
defined for you in the data that I've
reserved give me distribution from the
posterior a sample from that posterior
distribution so I can see the values I
care about namely the mean funniness of
this joke and give it back to me as a
panda's data frame and then let me go
plot it and in this case bouquet which
is really cool I can see given that my
my mean funniness for this joke tends to
be around four and this is a
computationally derived sample from the
posterior distribution given the model
that I derived that I laid out and the
observations that I recorded because you
can see this doesn't match any
distribution you would find in Syfy but
it is it is directly from the posterior
with support for us with MIDI so I can
also compare that joke between audiences
so let's say I've got the same joke and
I recorded a few different observations
so I've got the ratings at home I've got
some ratings at work who it seems to do
about the same but I got more people to
answer my joke at work and then a PI
data outside of this particular talk it
stroked you pretty well so I got some
sevens eights and nines so now I can I
can basically take the exact same model
except now I'm just going to define it
three times so I'll say you funniness
home new funding this work new funding
this PI data these are all going to be
the exact same priors defined now three
times with three different names and
I'll do the same thing with this model
I've got my observed fitness at home at
work in at p-- idea and i just map these
same standard deviations these Mews and
I go ahead and find my my map
click the infants button this is the
exact same slide as I showed you before
and I get my same pandas dataframe so
this doesn't make sense by itself these
are each individual samples from the
posterior we're going to talk about in
one second but you can think of them as
specific simulations given the model
given the data for all three of those
sample distributions and then I can
compare my MyHome distribution versus
work if you recall I have a few more
observations at work and we can see that
those actually warp the prior much
stronger so I'm almost certain that it's
about a 4 and with my work colleagues
whereas at home it's it's not quite as
clear and then at PI data it seems to be
shifted pretty far right word so I'm
pretty sure the joke lies around around
the 8 around the 8 line and then if you
see because we squish in this this
truncated normal distribution we can't
go past 10 we get sort of a spike at the
end so there's some likelihood that's a
10 joke really what else is really cool
is that I can do posterior integration
so I'm sorry interrogation so given that
I have this pandas dataframe like any
other pandas dataframe I just plotted it
like any other I can go do some summary
statistics on it so how confident can I
be that my joke will do better at pi
data than at home and that's just really
a summary stat count over this data
frame so I can do some some data frame
method chaining and say I want the
incidents that it's funnier PI data than
at home oh some those all up and divide
by the length of data frame it's about
80% confident that this joke does better
at PI data that doesn't my house and by
the same token I'm over 90% confident
that jokes is better at PI data than it
does it might work
and let's despite the the mean of those
ratings actually being identical so this
is this is purely due to the increased
confidence that gained from additional
data collection and because I have full
support for uncertainty in a
probabilistic model I can show exactly
what the what I expect the range of that
to be so this is what I would call a
joke of a model it fits fairly well for
a simple rating but the real interesting
part of this question comes not in
defining the model or not in
interrogating it but in saying what's
the right way to structure this formula
because what if you would say probably
defensively that jokes don't really
range from zero ten jokes are binary you
either laugh or you don't
well then turns out you can define a
model for that you could do you could
use you could treat you like a Bernoulli
trial and you could say what's the
hidden probability of my joke we'll get
a laugh or not what's the weight of this
coin so a couple other questions what's
the probability that a random person
finds my joke funny how many times can I
expect to tell this joke before I get a
laugh how sure am i that this joke is
better than another joke that my friend
told me with the same audience all of
these questions are fully supported
transparently within probabilistic
models and the answer to them is left as
an exercise to me so now I want to talk
a little bit about theory behind
Bayesian modeling this was a sticking
point for me for a long time and so I'm
hoping that my suffering can lead to
your enlightenment so I think everyone's
familiar with Bayes theorem but the
labels that we apply to it are important
so we've got probability of B given a
equals the probability of a given B
recall the likelihood time's the
probability of B alone which is our
prior divided by the evidence which is
the marginal likelihood and that all
equals the posterior so the posterior is
given this data and this model approach
what are we expected values for the
parameters of this model to be and it
turns out that this is a very intuitive
tool once you get your you get your arms
around it but it's actually really
difficult to solve real problems using
Bayes theorem purely
and the reason for that boils down to
the right-hand side so we'll just take
the numerator of this right-hand side
the likelihood times a prior so we'll go
through each of these individually
though the likelihood the probability of
a given B so that is the support for our
shows and parameters given the data how
likely is this model given the data that
we've observed and you can do that
pretty trivially it's not that hard so
here is in Python using Syfy thanks
again to javis Olaf on who you should
all support as sustaining members of M
PI so from sci-fi dedh stats import norm
and we can say for a given normal
distribution
get the probability density function for
some observed values and then assuming
that they're all independent we can just
multiply those together and we'll get
the probability that those values get
observed under that distribution and all
this happens sub-millisecond and this is
very easy to do so we can we can vary
them we can change the data we can
change the change to the probability
function and we can see what we expect
to be the outcome on the likelihood of
the model given the data now the
marginal likelihood so if we've got
probability of a given B then
probability of a is just the integral of
probability of a given B over all
possible values of B and it turns out
that that is probably really hard so for
models that are even a bit more than
trivial calculating the marginal
likelihood across all parameter values
is generally not possible analytically
and that's outside of some special cases
called called conjugate priors so if you
if you if you restrict yourself to very
constrained modeling choices where I say
given this model and this parameter its
prior comes from this distribution so
and I associate myself to specific rules
in terms of what chains into what then I
can sometimes analytically derived due
to math tricks but generally you don't
want to do that it's it's tough to to
make those choices so numerically you
can calculate a single integral really
well by summing up trapezoids and then
fubini's theorem tells us that you can
translate multi-dimensional integrals so
integrals over integrals into repeat
in applications of a single dimensional
integral but that is exponentially
complex so if you start doing this if
you start translating multiple
multi-dimensional integrals into
repeated single integrals and you do it
on your macbook it will start cooking
eggs and it'll take very long so we
don't want to do that and we need to
find out a way around it
so let's look back at Bayes theorem
again and let's consider for a single
value that we know that it's calculating
the denominator of this right hand side
is a difficult part so for a single
value let's say b2 we think that's
actually not that hard so we can
calculate the likelihood we can
calculate the the prior just by virtue
of having to find them and we do that
same thing for b1
so for any two values you can calculate
calculate the likelihood and prior for
p1 check it for p2 we can also
consequently calculate their their
division and this leads us to Monte
Carlo sampling so this is an example of
Monte Carlo sampling to find a to find a
circle it's a sample within a circle and
the idea is that we're just going to
select random points and then calculate
how likely are they to occur under this
under this model specification so
knowing the relative value of babe's
numerator we can randomly sample values
for B in order to determine the shape of
its posterior distribution right we can
ignore this denominator if we can just
find really good values for for B and
calculate how likely they are all going
to be under the posterior and we'll do
that using this ratio so we'll propose
the sampling algorithm we'll choose some
starting value for B call it B
hypothesize B sub H will compute Bayes
numerator for B sub H and then we'll
change it just a little bit we'll add
some epsilon to V sub page and calculate
the base numerator for that and if the
probability the likelihood of B 1 write
the perturbed piece of H is greater than
piece of age then we'll just say that's
our new hypothesized value and we'll
just keep doing that until we get to the
optimal value for B sub page that seems
like it work pretty well but what that
actually does is just create a hill
climbing
algorithm we're just gonna proceed in
one direction until we get the optimal
value and we're gonna stop and that
doesn't actually solve any of our
problems that we're trying to estimate
the distribution of this posterior
because it's gonna fail when we reach a
local optima and there's no support for
uncertainty we just have a single best
value so let's change this a little bit
rather than just directly accepting B
sub-1 if it's greater than piece of age
let's let's calculate if it's greater
than 1 if piece of 1 is greater than
piece of age we'll assign P sub H equal
P sub 1 but if it's less than piece of
age so if it's less likely than piece of
age we'll still assign it to V sub H
will still accept that value with
probability equal to B 1 over B H so if
it's much less we're probably not going
to go there but the closer and closer it
gets the the closer it gets in
likelihood to the value that we're
currently testing the more likely we'll
actually just switch anyway and what
this does is in last step is to profit
what this does is allow us to take non
hill-climbing jumps so I stole this
image ResearchGate
I think it's really good but we are no
longer proceeding directly toward the
middle we're actually bouncing around
the outside and so we're moving from to
the tails we're moving to the to the
areas of high density Russian moves the
high areas of high density and the exact
ratio that those areas of high density
are more likely than the areas of low
density and so this set is this this
rule this routine that we've proposed
now satisfies the Markov property so
every observation is not dependent on
the observation before it it's only its
memoryless and so what we've done is
created a Markov chain which at the
long-run assumes the probability
distribution of that posterior and the
little trick here is that the ratio of
bayes numerator for one value to Bayes
numerator for a different value is
actually the ratio of all of bayes
theorem for one value to all of Bayes
theorem for the others for the other
value we've gotten rid of this really
nasty integral
the marginal likelihood and gotten away
with a much easier computation that we
can do computationally so this is called
metropolis inkling it came from John
metropolis in the 1950s and it was
designed to run on the maniac
supercomputer and the maniac name I have
it written in the slide notes I forget
the exact the exact expansion but it was
a joke by John metropolis after UNIVAC
in ENIAC he came up with maniac and we
stopped doing all the Yaak computers and
that was that was the end of it
so John metropolis defined this in the
1950s and it's the the backbone of
Markov chain Monte Carlo analysis and
there have been improvements since then
so in the nineteen nineteen eighties
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo was was what was
hypothesized so it includes an idea that
we can have an analogy to momentum on a
frictionless surface on a frictionless
surface to inform steps in the Markov
chain so rather than having to sample
randomly we can remember the momentum
the Hamiltonian of our distribution and
much quicker converged to some value and
then fairly recently Andrew Gelman and
his team at Columbia came up with the
nuts the no you term sampling algorithm
which is how most of this is done today
so Stan IMC three train in a
probabilistic programming environment
now uses nuts but the backbone of it is
still metropolis and I would I think
that explanation of metropolis is really
intuitive so this is now a real
superpower that we have we have the
ability to design arbitrarily complex
nested models and then crank basis Bayes
rule and so we come up with posterior
distributions for each of the hidden
parameters in it we have the ability to
impart expert knowledge on to systems
into values for those models so we can
say what we think that this system works
this way and we'll choose any prior we
want for any value and we'll choose any
expansion of those priors that makes
sense including branches including if
statements conditionals all of that's
now on the table
and we have the ability to derive for a
given model structure a probability
distribution for the values which drive
that model structure so I think the core
of this talk is what common real world
problems if we now have this superpower
what Arya's that everyday - everyday
data scientists should be applying them
and I have three ideas I like deposit I
think their idea is that a lot of his
friends who pretty often that I think
there's their saw solved superiorly it
is a superior solution to use public
programming than more traditional
methods the first is model validation
when test data is expensive this is an
increasingly common problem and the age
of transfer learning when you train on
really large available data and try to
evaluate your model against scarce or
domain-specific data also systems that
can be encoded with pre-existing expert
knowledge we we find ourselves
automating a lot nowadays and generally
the people who have been doing those
jobs know a lot about those jobs and I
think we do a disservice if we don't
listen to them and finally problems that
require reasoning with uncertainty so if
you want to talk about the potential
impacts and the expected likelihood of
impacts for some decision Bayesian is
almost always the way to go
so model validation when test data is
expensive
again you have lots of situations where
you're trying to train a model on say
Wikipedia or some very large readily
available data set and then evaluate and
say well how does this model that I
trained on really general data work on
this really specific use case and
typically that date is not as readily
annotated you don't have some tests or
dev set that people have gone and
annotated for you so that you can test
your model and so a scenario that we've
run into at SMP is if you're working on
document classification which we do a
lot of we process financial forms so
10-qs 10ks aks these are all forms that
get submitted to the sec then we process
and make available to our clients so if
you have a lot of documents like this
and let's say some of them are labeled
and some of them part but your
populations aren't necessarily
homogeneous so we ran to a situation we
had two legacy systems one of them was
fully labeled going back several years
and one of them was not so the first
legacy system had performed better than
the other one and we had to assign
labels to these new documents while
being pretty sure that they didn't fit
the same distribution as the old
documents and so we'd like to automate
this how do we do it a little diagram
here we've got good training data we
want to train a model mat and it
predicted on a totally new set of data
that doesn't come from the same
population and this talk isn't about how
we did that this talk is about how we
prove that it worked so you've got your
officer who's going to evaluate these
predictions and you can treat this like
a coin flipping problem so you have a
classifier that classifier has some
under fall under line likelihood it's
going to be correct and what you're
trying to do is determine what is the
value of that of that probability of did
you get heads you get a correct
classification and so if we observe a
relatively small number of observations
and then we can define our model so in
pints III syntax we again just open up
this context manager and say with our
model as success model will define a
prior on the P the underlying
probability of success for Bernoulli
trials as just a uniform prior it has it
forms no information and will say given
our trials or if our P is lots of type
of but if our P is a probability of
success then what's the value what do we
expect to value that P to be and we can
come up with a full posterior derived
distribution that shows it's about
centered at 0.7 with support for
uncertainty so we know it could range as
low as zero point three or as high as
zero point nine and then again we can do
summary measures on the accuracy so
pulling down our data frame with all of
our prediction samples from the
posterior distribution we can say what's
the the mean probability of success and
then what's what in this case is called
a 90% credibility interval so out of all
these samples and we did 5,000 of them
what's what's the middle 90%
and when code that into an F string and
say well the mean accuracy is about 65%
and the 90% credibility credibility
interval and this is not a confidence
interval because we don't have we don't
have some sort of rationalization we
have to do it was like if we ran this a
thousand times then we would expect 90%
of those as those values come within
these thousand within these range it's
really just this is how confident we are
we're 90% confidence gonna fall in the
range zero point four to zero point
eight and this is this has full support
for in certainties so if we just go get
more trials we can narrow this histogram
from the posterior and that allows us to
make a pretty credible argument to
business stakeholders and say well if
you don't really like this then you
should go and take more data for us so
use case to these systems that make use
of expert knowledge so a lot of times
determining the correct structure for
graphical model is really hard and
that's that's where you sit you spend
the bulk of your time when you're
building these sorts of models is what
informs what what of intelligent priors
for the different parameters I'm going
to encode here and a lot of times the
people who are best qualified to answer
those questions aren't data scientists
so if you have a situation like we've
had where you're trying to improve some
system where a manual worker consumes
some raw resource and produces finished
work then you would really benefit from
talking to that person and if you
suspect well I can just fit a
probability distribution to each of
these each of these processes then
you're going to run to a situation where
there's a little bit more complexity
than you expect so a lot of times we'd
answer this in search where we were
trying to model searches that people
were running on our platform it turns
out that there are multiple types of
searches and if we just model them as
one giant one giant distribution we're
not going to get a very good result and
so in this case we've got three
different types of documents that that
this this person is consuming do we need
to treat them individually and we can
talk to them about water intelligent
priors to put on those
humans as far as time to completion
level of effort in order to complete
their work and create the stream of
finished documents so here's a little
bit more complex model and this will be
helpful to show off some of the
syntactical tricks in five mc3 but if
we've got let's say a document rate and
it's deterministic it can come from one
of three documents so we'll define a
discrete uniform distribution which
takes on one of three values zero one or
two with no prior likelihood for any
single document and will deform we'll
define normal priors for the standard
deviation and the mean for the for the
parameter which drives the exponential
of these documents so this this
exponential is time to completion it has
one parameter and that's going to be
driven by the rate so I have a normal
distribution and we'll define one of
these 4.1.2 duck three and by talking to
the person who has done this process in
the past for these different documents
they tell us the the first type takes
about an hour
the second type takes 20 minutes so this
will be the number per hour
and the last type takes six minutes we
can encode this directly crank it
through and just by observing one
document we can get an estimate for what
type of document was that given the
priors that we've gotten from our our
business user and just by saying this
took zero point three hours to to
process we can say we're mostly certain
that that's one that's the the second
document type with about equal
likelihood that it could be the first
one or the third one and if we can
observe them taking on more and more of
those types of documents and recording
the time that takes and complete them we
can narrow this distribution so we can
say with increasing likelihood what type
of document was this the third type of
problem that I think really lends itself
to probabilistic programming is when
you're reasoning about uncertainty so a
lot of times a question that we get has
data scientists is should we make this
change to our process given
improvement we suspect that you've made
what is this going to benefit us what's
it going to potentially cost us if we
make the change what's the worst-case
outcome what's the best case and how
sure are we that this situation will
improve because of your adjustment and
in an example that we've run into is
number of errors we have people who
process documents they make mistakes
sometimes we want to minimize those
mistakes so a really important metric is
the number of errors that they're making
however it's really expensive whenever
we put this model into production and
have them i've been executing on it in
real time so we don't have time to do it
through a b test we just want to say
well here's historical data here's the
new data how quickly can we know that
this is good or it's not so what I'm
gonna show you is about 15 observations
from old process vs. 5 observations from
new process with one really high outlier
here so we suspect that these are mostly
better but we've got 122 and we want to
know does that represent some spurious
outlier or is that an indicator of a
larger problem and how certain are we
have that so we can define we can take
these data we'll just mash them into a
data frame so we've got our value what
does concatenate those guys and then
groups so old process and new process
those are just labels and we are pretty
sure that these are not normally
distributed there they're heavy tails
and so a t-test here would be the way
that most statisticians would go about
doing this waters to a to t-test between
the means but that's actually assumes
behind the scenes that these variables
are normally distributed and in fact
we're almost certain that they're not
especially when we look at this new
process so we'll encode our model here
this takes advantage of Unicode syntax
so we've got with our model again going
into the context manager the group 1
mean is a normal distribution around
just the mean of the first group group 2
mean is mean of the second group we'll
put in reasonable values for high and
low standard deviation values and we'll
define a student T distribution for
these
use so rather than thinking a normal and
computing the difference between these
we're gonna use a t-distribution which
is heavy tails it takes for four
parameters so we've got the new which is
a measure of abnormality and we're gonna
take that to be really high which means
it's not going to be normal at all the
the lower this this new value is and
we've got one over 30 the less and less
normal this distribution is going to be
the more weight we put into the tails
we're gonna sign the MU to the group one
mean which kicked it up here
that's a prior the standard deviation is
a uniform distribution from one to ten
and we observed the y ones and the y
twos that we calculated here and then we
can also throw in a deterministic
variable which says if my there's we can
encode a deterministic variable which is
the difference of those means so Group
one mean Grannis - group two means
that's going to be a tracker within the
model that will continue to identify and
then we can plot and do analysis with so
here's our distribution the old
processes in blue the new process is in
sort of this pinkish color and we can
see we're kind of sure that the new
process is better but there's a lot of
uncertainty it's it spreads really
widely particularly because we have very
little data and one really high value
you can see pushing out on the edge
there but we can still articulate
exactly how short we are so we can show
our difference of means and this is just
plotting that deterministic variable
that we plugged into the model and say
well throw a red bar at zero and the
bulk of this distribution is greater
than zero so we're pretty sure we're
going to have fewer errors in exactly
it's about 75% of our posterior
simulations had fewer errors in our in
our new process than our old process and
this is a much more persuasive argument
than it with this histogram than just
this number being able to say well
here's the exact range of values that we
expect to achieve from the posterior
distribution of this model
so I like to talk a little bit about
where I see problems like programming
for the modern data scientist stack
first off I think it's ideal for
treating uncertainty as a first-class
citizen which i think is a requirement
when you're adjusting business processes
you have to be able to articulate how
uncertain how uncertain are you and what
are the best and worst cases scenarios
also you need to transparently specify
any of your assumptions I think too
often we we make modeling decisions that
have assumptions buried behind the
scenes and then don't transparently
interrogate what those assumptions are
and whether or not they fit our data but
when you are articulating a model
completely in Python to share in front
of the world you even have that option
you have to say exactly what your
assumptions are and how well they fit it
supports online updates so online
learning becomes increasingly in demand
a lot of what I would call a cookie
cutter machine learning model like what
you pull out of SK learn doesn't have
transparent support for online learning
but that's by default built into
probabilistic methods in small data
problems so frequently you're doing
analysis where data is expensive where
it takes manual effort in order to
evaluate what you've done and that's not
a world where you've got big data it
costs a lot of effort in order to get
each individual points you want to
maximize your support and then once
you're beyond some threshold of
certainty no stop stop sampling stop
answering that data and I think this
boils down to two views of machine
learning so one is that models should be
general in blackbox components you
should be able to from sq learn import
model model dot fit model dot predict
that's not what this is
so john Salvatierra what was a core
developer of Pi mc3 and he has this line
that black box machine learning is like
Bapat and a PI mc3 probabilistic
modeling is like Legos
so whereas Bop it is a toy that you take
out the Box you know works exactly like
you expect and that's pretty much all it
does Legos is a set of tools that you
use to build your own model
to reflect your system in an interrogate
crash breakdown rebuild I tend to prefer
the second type so these models are
built to mirror the problem at hand from
its first principles and just to close
there's an area of research in Bayesian
deep learning so deep learning some
would say is the ultimate black box
model you you can code very complex
systems you can download them directly
and apply them to your problem with no
transparency to what's happening but an
active area of research is applying
Bayesian methods to deep learning models
and the core strengths there is the
support for uncertainty so this comes
from a blog post by Alex Kendall who's a
researcher at Cambridge in computer
vision so the left image here is the
input to a depth measuring neural
network the middle image is the output
of that of that network so it's saying
the red is closer to the blue is further
away and the far right is the
uncertainty so the standard deviation of
the prediction so by fitting
distributions to model weights and
propagating through to the predictions
from that that model we can actually say
here's where we are not sure about our
prediction it's not a binary yes/no it's
not some pure rest value it is it has
this range of possible outputs which
there's a lot of examples out there but
that can save lives there was a I think
a situation where a Tesla self-driving
vehicle crashing at the back of a
semi-truck and when you go back to using
the model the the machine computer
vision model that was using and
propagate through uncertainty on the
weights of that model you can see that
it confused the the back of that semi
truck with the sky and it was pretty
sure than it was it was unsure but when
you're only making a binary or a
regression prediction and you don't have
support for uncertainty
bad things like that can happen
and that's all so I think I have a few
minutes for questions yeah yeah
so we talked about Bayesian learning
what about instead of a model of just in
standard deviation
yes the question is could you just
parameterize the distributions of the of
the neural network so I'm not sure I
follow that do you do you mean fit
distributions to the weights that the
neural network is is fitting right so
the trick there is you have to have a
distribution to sample from so if all
you're doing is fitting point estimates
for the weights of a neural network then
are you going to get is point estimate
outputs but if instead you fit a
distribution to those weights so you say
the weight matrix for this hidden layer
is no longer set of points as a set of
distributions which are each
parameterised according to some
parameters then you can do what you're
talking about right because you have
support for uncertainty and that
propagates through the entire model so
rather than it being like a point wise
of matrix multiplication now you've got
distributions that are summarized by
points and you can then sample from
those and see well based on this this
outcome in the uncertainty with each of
the components that led to that outcome
how uncertain are we does that make
sense yeah it's a really hot area of
research there's a mips workshop next
month probably the premier machine
learning conference in the world so this
this area is is is really hot I would
encourage you to engage deeper
yeah
so one of the core assumptions here is
that the data that you're predicting
over is their iid so they're
independently and identically
distributed so saying we want this value
to be at this edge of the distribution
and we're going to predict where that
comes by the definition is not possible
because you're saying that no point has
any any bearing on any other point yeah
but you can't you could certainly
identify well we would learn more if we
found a value at the tail of this
distribution the trouble would be
predicting when that's going to occur
like if your model has less certainty
that say is that the tail if you would
label that
I think I think if you include say very
far off tail points back into your
training data set that's obviously going
to lead you to either better estimates
of your uncertainty or better
predictions if you try to move sort of
the the weight of the curve leftward so
to speak but as far as saying at which
point I'm going to learn from the most I
think the best you can hope for is is
that you you widen your uncertainty
bounds so if you say I'm this far and
certain you get lots of points that are
way outside of your parameter
distribution then I think that tells you
that your uncertainty may not be correct
and so perhaps you've got by a sample
data though but yeah ideally if you're
doing an online sort of model evaluation
like the one that I talked about that
would be that we brought in to expand
your uncertainty estimate by default so
you'd be saying well now including these
values which are much wider I'm this
uncertain
I'm much less certain in my my
predictions yeah
have how do you handle the bridges you
have to cross from deep learning and
statistical tribe terminology to the
business or organizational business
owner vocabulary when you were you're
talking about that they don't trust
Bayesian and they'd only heard that word
because it mistake sometimes yeah about
introducing uncertainty at least making
it more transparent they're saying
what's not transparent so my favorite
example of this is the confidence
interval so almost any executive when
they're evaluating a model or trying to
say we should do this because it's gonna
have this positive outcome it's gonna
say well what's your what's your
confidence and the intuitive explanation
to a business person for a confidence
interval from a frequentist statistics
perspective is really difficult it's a
hard thing to explain to business folks
to say well if we were to run this
example this many times then we expect
that the long-run average of those of
those observations would fall within
this range experts of the time yeah so
basically basic incredible 'ti of
interval has the interpretation that I
am this confident this is going to occur
and that's it so I think it's a much
more intuitive way to go from Basel and
speak to manager speak because you are
not having to couch it in statistical
long run averages you're saying based on
the data that we've observed in the
model that we've laid out here is our
confidence
[Applause]